desenvolvido toda a gente jogar com
muita atenção e certa maneira pensa em
improvisar aqui um pouco porque vou já
dizer não é de todo é minha praia como o
poder não ter assim uma vitória de jesus
estão fazendo muita falta uma guerra é
bem mais fácil da caneta porque nós
temos que entrar com aquela remota está
melhor pessoas até 1 bilhão de pessoas
quando os dias quer ganhar o referendo
mil pessoas mas é muito fácil essas
pessoas serem visíveis
eu vim aqui falar de uma igreja pra mim
é faxina mas ao mesmo tempo em que até
agora em que é tanto porque é um líder é
isso que mais domina o mundo que a
mudança de opinião
quem tá em um privilégio ou
eventualmente é potencializar vou
comunicar para massas ainda que limitava
a consciência do que pode mudar o mundo
nós vivemos sonolento com uma questão
fundamental no mundo dos telejornais não
é um dos 19 anos é o mundo que filtra é
que o resto do mundo questionável é isso
que me inquieta a ter o meu nome sempre
é alguém que você está em quinto com 15
quem tem mais que isso é para quem tem
menos 20
eu queria dizer uma coisa eu não quero é
em si um tendencial que no portugal de
hoje diminuiria com líder
uma mulher foi detida e fugiu para o
brasil essa interagem que seleciona um
problema não fui contra contra o mundo
do mal da minha mãe e muitos de vocês
eventualmente não sabem é minha mãe mas
eu não tenho vergonha que esta é minha
grande virtude é não ter vergonha de
quem sou de onde vem eu vou interior
tem de ir lá e falar sobre mim e convém
falar para as câmeras
mas este é parte mais difícil pra mim
talvez aquela tabela
aos olhos dos outros porque foi
precisamente por não conhecer que isso
que um turnê na pessoa que eu sou e olhe
para as coisas todas com esta onde
tiravam ralf que é sobre ela que foi em
caruaru
eu sempre penso é onde eu cheguei
e porque é que eu cheguei penso que esse
percurso difícil e amargo
a maioria das pessoas eventualmente se
aos 20 anos levado tivessem uma empresa
pensaria o meu deus
e agora eu tinha plena é pensar que tem
de ser boa profissional tem de ser
seleccionada e de repente o meu mundo
caiu de repente
não é suposto filho cuidar do pai ou da
mãe é suposto filho cuidar de si pois
vai me acontecer o contrário e tô aqui
mas quando acontece isso nós não temos
preparação porque como dizia eu já me
esquecido o nome do ouro do fantástico
primeiro tempo foi mostrado nos estados
unidos que dizia nós não podemos pôr
porque vai continuar sendo assim pois
não podemos prever o que vai acontecer
no sítio eu não sei o que vai acontecer
na minha filha eu gostaria que não é bom
mas é com ele produzir levava que as
pessoas têm de saber viver adaptar antes
já falamos disto muitas vezes aqui hoje
eu fiz pelo preâmbulo para vos dizer
quem sou explicados que o clube será
seguir tem importância que tem para mim
e fez de mim não ser humano melhor ou
pior mês fez de mim eu sou consciente do
justiça que eu tenho
sabendo que onde o trabalho mais
importante do que fazer é dizer certa é
fazer pelo que se bem que a palavra
chave pra mim é o pai
um desses indivíduos entre o bem eo mal
nós fazemos bem feito ou fazemos mal
feito e em conseqüência para quem
trabalha onde o trabalho pode ser
tenebrosa porque pode por isso
simplesmente liquidar vidas que não há
vidas que sejam reduzidas a é nova e que
possuía com condicionada
eu venho aqui dizer também é que
qualquer líder que seja um bungee inter
pode fazer o coronel salem e disputar
para frisar 30 às vezes você monta sua
intervenção vem aqui dizer nós todos
podemos saber lidar com a frustração de
não salvar as vidas todos no mundo mas
falávamos algumas e comunicar isto é ter
a consciência de que mais que eu digo é
conseqüência do que o digo uma multidão
pode salvar vidas e eu não preciso
desviar
eu não preciso ser militar e não se está
num contexto de guerra eu posso estar
aqui em portugal e vamos vamos mostrar
como e dentro de constância é que é
possível mas primeiro estava partilhar
convosco algumas das frases que nem que
é tão levaram a pensar em tudo que sou
partilhar convosco hoje o torcedor é na
implementação direta no reino unido
enquanto ministro dizia que a tolerância
dizer que não
ora se nós pensarmos que em maioria das
pessoas têm muita facilidade em ser mãe
sim muitas vezes quase sempre assim
serão lidas
a maioria dos policiais que fazem aquilo
que o outro imã tão bem disse no final
da segunda guerra mundial são estes são
estes que são testados não presentes
junto no futuro com o cabo que deixaram
porque deixar os outros a convicção de
que o que fizeram foi tão grande foi tão
melhor que é preciso que alguém diz
continua tarefa e isto não se em
contexto não se impõe
estou se sentou num sentido eu começar a
horas a falar não interessa nada o que
eu digo entre essas forças e sentem o
que eu estou dizendo com intensidade com
que eu estou a dizer que se
eventualmente que o que eu estou a
dizer-vos toca ao ponto de vós e às
vossas vidas em cada uma das profissões
que vai entender em laser
vamos fazer aquilo que eu vi que na
minha perspectiva é tão singela
perspectiva melhor realização humana
cross polêmica mas depois a lembranças
tão horrorosa então o papel de deus
quanto aquela que fundamento pouco o
partido nazi em nome de uma pessoa ou
empresa
um reino um povo um líder o site todos
dizer ganhei no exemplo mais atual e fui
pro passado que é preciso quando
pensamos na liderança no liderança de
opinião e de massas que houve exemplos
tenebrosos no mundo dos quais nunca nos
podemos esquecer que o piloto que nos na
mesma fatalidade porque porque o partido
nazi o que fez foi intoxicado massas com
mensagens que por ser uma ponte rolante
que parece fazer sentido porque nunca
tiveram motivos e de repente essa
megalomania transformou os uma coisa
mais horrorosa que aconteceu no mundo em
que vivemos e foi tudo com palavras foi
tudo com o que nós temos aqui fazer hoje
bastou alguém ter o dom da palavra e
conseguir enganar tanta gente esquece
aquilo que achava partilhar convosco é
algo grave foi a droga e josh sheehan
campi ou a bomba num duro no grupo de
que mais gostei de minha mãe quer que eu
tomava banho quente
agora expõe o mistério feito pelo
estónio em angola
ae
aqui é meu papel aqui é novo lino
o estilo exigente - moniz já tinham
destruído
não não é a quantidade do boi ou viveu
nelson borges coelho devia ter
apresentado primeiro mas o quanto foi
mais rápido que eu esperava muito mais
de cinco estrelas cnn famoso repórter
era pivô que se tornou também o líder do
peão
isto aconteceu como devem ter percebido
no haiti no terrível terremoto em 2010
ou ainda 5 foi enviado para relatar o
que estava a acontecer e aconteceu o
episódio em que se tornaram marcantes
porque são os dois episódios mostram
como é que de repente os acontecimentos
podem ser culpados e transformados numa
realidade que não é realidade é fiel à
realidade de quem lá estava 15 estava
aqui num dia em que já sabia o mundo
sabia que após o terremoto é via uma
espiral muitas viagens
os haitianos no terremoto que dizimou
300 mil vidas
de repente não tinha nada e pretende
roubar uns aos outros e o cenário de
violência constantes e eu fui preço
local sabendo que havia imenso jovem
sempre neste tipo de actividade violenta
e critica a pergunta que o bicho é quem
era a notícia aqui quem era o viver
daqui porque anda sem culpa se quis
filmar ilustração mundo
salvador desta criança de 12 anos que
precisava de ajuda
alguém quer ajudar num filme ajudar
alguém alguém internacional de ajuda
ponto não tem ciência
o episódio que mais marcou nesta neste
enviado especial nos 5 em haia no haiti
em 2010 foi um episódio que não encontra
na internet que o episódio do mundo em
que é uma criança de cinco anos que teve
oito dias soterrado e foi salvo com
muita dificuldade o corpo esteve para o
desafio votar demonstrava ser salvo mas
pergunta à esposa ou a câmera grava tô
puxou uma mãe não parou a câmera ea
situação que eu faço e sai
e politicamente incorreto na rtpi meses
colegas que criticam por pensar assim
mas eu penso de um elemento assim e nós
podemos do expira o fato de enfrentar
nós podemos respirar o fato de vista
cirurgião
nós não podemos definir o caráter humano
e quais creiam cheerleaders do que nós
temos pensar pra mim é nisto há uma
hierarquia de valores clara na vida vida
morte um elevado imposto o resto
e se eu quiser que os outros me
acompanham quiser que os outros percebam
porque eu estou e porque de certa forma
pode ser um exemplo para os outros
eu tenho que dar o exemplo e em
circunstâncias como esta
um exemplo o ensino exemplo ainda que o
que é correto fazer quando em algum
momento das nossas vidas vocês não soube
era aí que é correto fazer se acredita
que a resposta não está em vocês noel é
a resposta está lá fora no que os outros
precisam no que os outros esperam que
seja a vossa resposta eu só consigo
ativar a confiança do meu público seus
telespectadores porque eu tenho uma
postura de honestidade moral intelectual
que os fãs conhecerem em formato novo em
que os ver em mim entro nessa vontade
apenas plantar aprovado com cidade
intelectual e moral eu subo em todos os
meus princípios e não há razão nenhuma
para quem continua inscrita na televisão
portanto para mim este é o capítulo
máximo o mais importante que nós temos
de cultivar em cada dia das nossas vidas
seja lá qual for a profissão que venham
escolher faça no bairro não têm que ser
os melhores
tem que ter a certeza de que o exemplo
que estão ali shah
é o maior é o bairro de hoje o movimento
vou partilhar convosco algo que me
orgulho imenso
é a história de um jovem que tem hoje
você times chama estudante esteve preso
11 metros por um crime que não cometeu
eu conhecia o lugar do ar o mês de maio
fui vê-la prisão
estava preso em sapatos não tinha um par
de sapatos quer que eu fiquei
absolutamente inquieta com que o mas
como é que é possível ter empreendido em
portugal um jovem por um crime que não
cometeu história seria longa para
explicar é sempre fazer publicidade de
pesquisa deve visitar a reportagem
procurou os motivos mas isso para dizer
o seguinte o caso do leandro é talvez
das histórias mais novas da minha vida
ele ligou emocionado é porque em cada
profissão que tenhamos nós podemos
renovar uma vida está assim sempre
apenas porque nos damos ao trabalho de
perceber o outro do vídeo não ficarmos
sentados à espera que um dia aconteça
dentro do hospital livre dentro tem uma
vida pela frente
foi abusado sexualmente dos 4 aos 12
anos foi para uma instituição e foi
vítima do preconceito foi preso pelos
abusos sexuais que o lobo mina e hugo
leandro e essa pessoa
o setor o setor pediu a absolvição do
leandro é isso naturalmente espera que
aconteça espero que sim
é minha primeira prioridade de passagem
deputados a segunda é que já ouvi
não
rosa
e que o que a crise será lenta e chamou
só podia mostrar pra galera
eu mesmo não esperava ganhar novos
modais não cometeu
cientistas no momento em que os bichos
falavam que eu não quero nada eu só
quero curtir a minha liberdade é só isso
era só isto é mesmo só isto na vida do
que é importante estarmos aqui vivos é
percebermos que estamos aqui vivos temos
que saber usufruir da nossa liberdade
porque no limits a felicidade que nos
move não é possível
senna visto obrigado